crazy theory i think the marvel
cinematic universe is going to give us
the secret defenders although they think
they're actually going to call it the
secret avengers
we've kind of talked about that before
here on geek culture explained we'll
talk about a little more in depth here
since that's the whole point of this
video
so what are the secret defenders okay
one the clock back to the 1970s in
marvel comics and he had a guy named roy
thomas
roy thomas was writing a comic about
doctor strange the problem was dr
strange couldn't hold a comic to save
his life
and so ultimately marvel cancelled it
and so in order to finish the story
roy thomas wrapped it up in an
incredible hulk comic and then
in the name of the submariner comic fans
loved these crossovers and so when
marvel featured number one in 1972 which
was the first of the comics we were
talking about
where marvel would introduce characters
and teams just to see if they would sell
they brought these guys together on a
team called the defenders fans loved it
so it got its own solo series
and lasted quite some time originally it
was dr strange the incredible hulk name
of the submariner eventually you got
silver surfer then you got valkyrie you
got fire lord you got a handful of
characters over the years the roster got
enormous
eventually it got cancelled after a
hundred some odd issues
marvel brought it back later on and
something called the new defenders
wasn't as good as the original they
canceled that and then launched it again
in the 1990s with a title called
secret defenders now that's where things
got interesting secret defenders was a
great concept
but terribly executed so the way this
would play out and we'll use characters
from the marvel cinematic universe to
basically explain this
is that say dormammu broke out of the
dark dimension and started running a
muck across
the universe doctor strange would read
off a handful of tarot cards which would
basically reveal what his roster is
going to be
in terms of the people that he needs to
defeat dormammu he would then go and
grab like the incredible hulk and
spider-man
and captain america and thor and they
would all go face off against thoramamu
and once dormammu was defeated the team
would dissolve
when the next threat showed up dr
strange would run off another set of
tarot cards
and maybe some of those members would
return but for the most part it would be
a wholly different roster
it was a genius concept that again was
terribly written but i think we're gonna
get that in the marvel cinematic
universe
and i think it's all predicated on the
actions and the events
of loki and the reason why is because
what we know is that the multiverse has
returned at the end of loki we know that
it's all back now and with the
multiverse comes an infinite number of
possibilities
we know that the ultimate evil version
of kang is back because
if any number of possibilities exist so
does that possibility of that version of
kang returning
and we know he basically ended up
winning because at the end of loki he
now created the tva
instead of it being immortus and so
because of that now we have
all these different universes out there
multiverse of madness seems to be
predicated on the idea that with all
these universes now being recreated
assuming that the ancient one was wrong
about the multiverse existing in doctor
strange one i don't know how you really
square that circle
that in essence you now have a litany of
different possibilities and villains
that exist out there
alternate reality versions of characters
that are evil and are twisted
they could bring in something like the
cancer verse those of you guys who don't
know the cancer verse was a universe
introduced in the story called the
thanos imperative and was basically an
alternate reality
where no one could die and then beings
like shumagorath referred to as the many
angled ones shumagorath of course being
the villain that we're probably gonna
see in doctor strange too
ended up conquering that universe and
then turning all the superheroes into
really twisted evil versions of
themselves
those are the possibilities that you
could see there's an universe out there
where thanos is part of the avengers
whatever the case happens to be
villains like shumo gorath and so on
will present themselves
as credible threats beyond the ability
for normal avengers to handle
and so in order to cope with those
threats you are going to need people who
have basically traversed the multiverse
characters like the scarlet witch loki
doctor strange
probably baron mordo somebody along
those lines i don't necessarily think
we'll get a secret avengers
secret defenders film immediately in the
middle of phase four or even the
beginning of phase five
but i think that doctor strange two will
set the stage for that
doctor strange 2 i think is going to
give us this concept or this idea
that there are some threats out there
that are so incredibly powerful
that it requires an equally powerful
team to defeat them
we know loki is already wildly capable
in terms of the magic we've seen him use
but we also know richard e grant's
version of loki revealed loki is
way more powerful than he thought he was
it's just he didn't have an occasion to
use those powers
we saw him use enchantment powers that
we thought only belonged to sylvie
originally
we saw that richard e grant's loki cast
a gigantic illusion
and presumably loki's going to be able
to do the same thing so we literally saw
what his powers could become
and they'll probably become even greater
than that we know scarlet witch
is already more powerful than the
sorcerer supreme at the end of juan
division when agatha harkness made that
statement
assuming she was even telling the truth
regardless we've got some powerful magic
users out there
and what better way to bring together a
kind of secret defender's-esque team
modeled off the 1990s comic book run
than to say
villains like shumagorath or dormammu or
nightmare
or mephisto who we all want to see has
somehow broken free of their captivity
and that now it's going to take some of
the most powerful magic wheelers across
the entirety of the marvel cinematic
universe
to defeat those guys the funny thing
about this is that with all the power
we've seen those guys display
they're almost nothing in comparison to
some of the beings who are out there
there are guys out there like zom zom is
so incredibly powerful
it took the actions of the living
tribunal in effect the second most
powerful being under
god to defeat that guy it's crazy how
powerful he is
not even doctor strange wants to summon
zom if zom were to face off against
somebody like dormammu for example
zom would crush dormammu and not even
buy a little bit it would be a massacre
those are the kind of threats that we're
talking about and so you're going to
need a very powerful magical team
to defeat those guys and having them
operate what is essentially
in secret not because they're hiding
their actions from everybody
but because they're taking place out
there in parts of the multiverse that
people just don't know
exist is a great idea it's a great way
to expand beyond the existing landscape
of the marvel cinematic universe
and give us some more interesting and
cool stuff i really hope that happens
but i'm curious to see if it does at the
very least it would give us a kind of
expansion to the things that we're used
to
i mean the reality is if we're looking
at what's going on in loki and we're
looking at doctor strange two multiverse
of madness we're looking at
a lot of the projects that we have we
know the multiverse is there but what
comes out of it
is anybody's guess again an infinite
number of universes means an infinite
number of possibilities
a lot of the theories that i've seen
from you guys which i think have a lot
more credibility now
than they did before loki even launched
or even before juan division
is that one of these alternate universes
have the x-men in it and that's how
they're going to get the x-men in the
mcu they're going to end up crossing
over
one of the big theories that i've heard
here is that the multiverse being reborn
is eventually going to lead to the
multiverse collapsing and that what
they're going to do
is they're basically going to kind of
combine things so the sony spider-man
films the venom film the toby mcguire
spider-man films and the villains you
saw there
the andrew garfield spider-man films and
the villains you saw there they're all
their own individual universes
the fox x-men films are their own
individual universes deadpool exists in
that fox x-men film universe but they
are all part of the multiverse that
exists in the marvel cinematic universe
and that when it's all said and done
that it's all going to be condensed down
into a singular universe
and what we'll have left is basically
what marvel wants to keep so we'll have
like the x-men who have been rolled into
the universe now and we'll have
whatever villains that marvel wants to
keep from the saudi villain spider-man
universe
in the main marvel cinematic universe
now and so on and so forth that's a big
theory that's going
on and i really believe it i think
that's a great idea that the multiverse
is basically only back temporarily
and it's just a way for mobile to bring
in stuff that they would otherwise have
one hell of a time trying to explain
how it exists in the marvel cinematic
universe in the first place i'm curious
to see if that's the case
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section one of the best
things about the return of the
multiverse in the marvel cinematic
universe is that
any number of possibilities can happen
there's no limit here anymore
right there's no real basic tangible
only this number of things could happen
things are going to follow this
particular form and function anything
can happen now
we don't know exactly how long the
multiverse will go on for it could be
that it's going to stay here forever
and that's basically it right that the
idea of tom hardy's venom and the idea
of
tom holland playing spider-man but in
the sony universe as opposed to in the
marvel cinematic universe
assuming that the deal they worked out
does not allow tom holland to stay in
the mcu
for any lengthy measurable time outside
of spider-man 3.
it all just means that doctor strange
could go to that universe snatch up tom
holland and call it a day
the idea of miles morales and and
spider-gwen and spider-ham and all those
characters that we saw from spider-man
into the spider-verse
they can cross over into the mcu now
there's any number of possibilities here
it's an exciting time
to be a fan of comic books and comic
book movies
it's amazing i'm i'm sorry i'm so
excited people this is a really exciting
time you know what i mean
it's a really exciting and fun and cool
time so i'm curious
what your all's thoughts are on this
theory the secret defenders seeing what
kind of characters cross over
and let me know what theories you
ascribe to let me know if you guys are a
fan of the idea
that the multiverse is basically going
to be marvel's cinematic universe just
kind of
picking and choosing what they want to
keep and once they've gotten everything
they wanted the multiverse condenses
back down to a singular universe
and the stuff they keep is the stuff
that stays everything else gets
destroyed and the multiverse will
collapse
and that's basically it let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section i'm really excited to hear your
theories i love what it is that you guys
have to say
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace